from two then East then King then Queen
some had waited all night a patient
reflective audience to see a moment of
history but also just to say goodbye old
and young they lined the street they
even brought their dogs
making new friendships among strangers
brought together in a moment of mourning
I got to see my goodbye
just heartbroken
heartbroken
never ever ever
ever see this again that's the Duke of
Edinburgh that I got from Prince Philip
that's the promise I made to serve the
queen
for many this grief is very real
my mom was born the same year as the
queen and she had a sister and she went
through the War years guides see Rangers
at the same time as the queen and she
died in February so I just felt it was
sort of faith that I should come not
just for the queen but for my mum
whether they simply watched or whether
they filmed the power of this moment was
palpable
Touchstone
Touchstone for us and for the world I
think it's remarkable for a divided
country to come together like this
she's a one-off it's a moment in history
in a moment in time and the queen means
so much to everybody in Scotland and
it's just a yeah a very poignant
thing for everybody I think whenever you
get down into Westminster London it'll
be multiplied goodness no so many times
you have to make it there
you can't ever do it again
and as they will in London they queued
for the chance to file past the coffin
taking their turn for a solemn and
Silent show of respect
it was uh quite emotional
I took a big breath before I went in
and then I did a little bow by our
coffin and to see that it was a Scottish
Crone on the top was lovely to see she's
Queen of the Scots she was declared that
wasn't she
so she's uh the Queen of England but
she's Our Queen
for her last few hours on Scottish soil
it's people saying they're farewell Greg
Milam Sky News Edinburgh